on CNN Bernie Sanders was asked if
America would ever go socialist hmm this
is the president America will never be a
socialist country will that hold true if
you're elected president if I am elected
president we will have a nation in which
all people have healthcare as a right
whether Trump likes it or not
we are going to make public colleges and
universities tuition-free they are going
to raise the minimum wage through to a
living wage of at least 15 bucks an hour
and whether Trump likes it or not when I
talk about human rights you know what
that also means it means that our kids
and grandchildren have the human right
to grow up in a planet that is healthy
and habitable clap clap clap alright
it's the golden rule of socialism when
asked about how it works focus on the
ends and skip the means cuz in the end
we all want free stuff health care
school cheeseburgers free anything is
awesome especially if you believe that
free anything actually exists it doesn't
take the tuition-free joke more than
eight million student borrowers have
defaulted on their federal loans for
higher education why is that thanks to
all that free and easy money from the
loans there's no incentive for colleges
to cut admission cost and no reason not
to go to college education costs tripled
debt exploded now the streets are paved
with English majors college
administration's ballooned because the
loans inflated the tuition it looked
like it was free but now you're broke
which means you can't buy cars goods or
a home because you're busy paying off
Uncle Sam that's how you kill industries
that's socialism it's a drag on the
economy and it's a drag on you still so
many think that if you vote socialist
all your debts are forgiven if students
are debt free then colleges must be cost
free free building's free books free
beer free you free me socialism's talent
is getting people like Sanders to lie
about free because who doesn't want a
free life capitalism it's such a drag
like gravity it's a downer but if
America's slow death is boring then
let's just skip to the finish line to
Venezuela where Maduro
detained a reporter for showing video of
PEEP
eating from a garbage truck oh look free
food and a socialist paradise that's
what you call a Bernie burger welcome
back Dana
see I wrote that down there welcome back
Dana yes I forgot you just couldn't
speak it from your heart I always think
that if somebody's away that's the first
person you should go to oh that's an
interesting theory yes it is I want to
talk to you bout this poll because
you're like polls that polls and charts
let's put this poll up here this poll is
very depressing yes
56% of registered voters between
eighteen to twenty four favor
mostly socialist economic models yep
48 percent of voters between 25 to 34 it
said the same thing that's scary and sad
do you care to 5 and older or like no no
any of that and I think that's partly
because we've talked before about having
to teach the lesson over and over again
about our system and why it works and
the other thing is is that it shows just
that you have to take it seriously
because one of the things I'll say about
the group between 18 and 34 that they
saw the financial crisis yeah their
parents went through maybe their parents
lost our job or maybe they were
graduating around the time of the
financial crisis so the market was tough
and so unfortunately the other thing
that you see is that rush and say
unfortunately this is just a fact you
know people who will say I'm fiscally
conservative but socially liberal right
and you think that there's a lot of
those people if you look on a graph it's
actually not true the most amount of
people are in the socially conservative
fiscally liberal you know I don't like
those people a lot of those people are
watching I'm kidding but they think
there's a theory that the government can
do it better and one thing I would say
about the free college thing and it just
shows a real lack of innovation if you
look at somebody like former governor of
Indiana mitch daniels who's now the
president of Purdue University they knew
that they had a problem with school
tuition is going up so how did they
figure they didn't just said give it
away for free they figured out a way to
work with employers so that employers
that think they want to hire you and
your junior when you're a junior I think
they want to hire you they start paying
you then so that they help defray the
cost of tuition so that you will then
have a job going through and it's worked
really well but that's an innovative way
to do things that's exactly right that's
actually a solution that that helps deal
with up
promised right what we see from Bernie
and the left generally jesse is just the
promises right well it's typical
liberalism you create a problem and then
you swoop in and try to fix it
I'm gonna go surface I'm not gonna talk
polls or facts I'm looking at Bernie
Sanders Sarah and I'm thinking to myself
this guy's lost his fastball he seemed
rusty to me his cadence was plotting
dead uh he seemed boring the audience
was not electrified I caught some of
this last night unfortunately and I have
to say something and it's just brutally
honest he is not good-looking enough to
be President Bernie Sanders this is Kay
but he knows it and I'll say it he is
not good-looking enough to be the
president when you have a president
you're inviting them into your home for
four years you want to be able to look
at them they have to do telegenic you
have to be comfortable with them Bernie
Sanders is just not handsome enough to
be all right a commander-in-chief
I predict within three minutes you're
gonna get a text from your mother and
your mother is gonna make you apologize
to Bernie Sanders that any moment any
but I will say no if we want to talk
about hip eye in the sky in the green
new deal that he's pushing they just ran
the numbers on this thing
unbelievable nearly a hundred trillion
dollars over ten years and guess how you
pay for it one the only way you can pay
for the green new deal is if you raise
everyone's taxes making over $30,000 a
year to a hundred percent everybody in
America can't make more than thirty
thousand dollars that's the only way you
can pay for this stuff and he doesn't
have a plan besides taxing everybody
Donald Trump does he wants to grow the
middle class and you look at the news
right now you have Jeep now announcing a
new plant in Detroit 63 hundred new jobs
created good-paying jobs with billions
more invested in that great city and and
I think the proof is in the pudding the
proofs in the pudding wand
yeah I guess that Harley saw the proof
that's why they left you know my
thinking on this is most Americans agree
with Bernie I mean that's what's scary
is well it is it's I know but I'm just
saying you know you
talk about socialism like it's the end
of the world like people who are
Americans who love capitalism of our
society don't understand what Bernie's
talking about this is what he said last
night he said I'm talking about
democratic socialism it doesn't mean
that the government takes over the means
of production or there's no more private
property what it means is that you have
protections so that people can for
example retire with dignity so that
people have security I'm not right
dignity right but here's a but he would
think you know what when Bernie was
asked well how do you pay for it because
I think that's your question I think
that was the heart of it he said
something burned he said Amazon how much
taxes do they pay his biggest company
answer they're not paying state they pay
state and local but they don't pay
federal taxes and then we look back at
their record they pay federal payroll
taxes but they don't pay federal taxes
like we're talking about on income it's
a solutions always taxes so and then you
think about other big companies like GE
or some of the back some of the
companies they don't pay taxes they say
oh oh you know what this is so
maybe it's how about the Trump tax come
on Madame is on Amazon's not paying any
taxes in New York because the Socialists
chased them out of New York oh yeah I
want to get more get in here it seems to
me the solution for everything is
taxation not creation yeah why don't you
think of this before now I don't know it
just dawned on me you know I listen we
can have a whole debate over the
economic philosophy over this it still
it is Charlotte's Joy's numbers on the
polls but I think you know what I see
going on the Democrat Party right now to
me there's more sophistication from a
policy perspective unlike a college
president election then there isn't this
party I mean this the sort of free stuff
that they're advocating they might as
well be advocating for the cheeseburgers
that you brought up earlier hmm but I
burger but I know if you created a
garbage truck and surfer and called them
Bernie burgers it would go great
probably yeah but listen Bernie raised
ten million dollars for almost three
hundred and sixty thousand donors 5.9
million in one day the establishment
democrat party in 2020 is acting exactly
like the establishment republican party
in 2016
and which they said there's no way it
could ever be Trump this isn't going to
happen when you look at the polls when
you look at the money when you look at
the energy I think it's completely
behind Ernie and this time they can't
rig the primary against him like they
didn't really have a real job before
becoming a politician he wrote erotic
fiction okay you know what you know what
I wanted to say though I mean Dana was
saying this thing about the young people
the numbers and how the young people are
more apt to say yes to socialism than
the seniors and I think to myself boy
that's ironic isn't it the seniors get
Social Security Medicare be a bad 6:50
yeah well I think those people are the
older folks and guess what they're the
ones who say no but they're the ones
that are benefiting from socialism
successful Wars